this is the one I think I'm most excited
about crashing an x-wing using my
favorite ship into the surface of the
Death Star just like a plywood platform
with like a bunch of like plastic junk
glued onto it which at first
just looks like a mess this is like a
pencil case like Tupperware but then you
put that coat of gray primer over
everything and all just blends together
you know like oh it's future stuff go
ahead what's the difference between this
stuff and universe I'm gonna drop it
okay you guys ready 3 2 1 go that on
that would pretty straight yeah I'll
grab fire let's try it again
these things are cushioning it oh wow
yeah we go wildly the Death Star is
right so good I can't believe ring yeah
and it has to we went through this and
the timing blew it again questions for
you Josh believe oh it we have
instructions no we can follow up online
we did it we built it poorly Casa go for
another round
let's go again
yep
here we go three two come on yeah this
book thing uh-huh Artie's hanging in
there there he goes
hey Luke I wish I would have it flying
straight but it's you know it's out of
control he's crashing
yeah I get all that